[Music]
and ghost texts news ghost texts
submitted by Deez Nuts hundreds of
people are Seaver and amout of context
text messages from friends and family
sex trafficking
I thought it was like honey I didn't
cheat it was the ghost the ghost dick
yeah come outside and it's like like
yeah it's on Twitter [ __ ] everybody
needs to get on Twitter oh you already
know right is it people that died it
like saw like for example let's say you
got a text from me
and we hang out all the time right and
you gotta text for me and I'm like hey
TIFF come outside I'm in the white truck
and you're like what are you talking
about and I'm like come outside now
hurry and then you're like what are you
talking about and then like you call me
and you're like bro why are you texting
me this and I'm like I'm not texting you
anything what are you talking about so
apparently sex traffickers are getting
like other people [ __ ] and being like
come outside like sisters like I don't
know how they're figuring it out but oh
my god
careful people if you get one of those
like don't look out the window cuz I'm
they know they're talking to you you
know like they come outside
I got cameras what if I go on they drive
away
oh wait wait don't you come out you come
out there like this please I need some
flesh we're good to monetize I'll show
your body okay okay we're good yeah so
apparently hundreds of people got all
these ghosts texts from people that even
like have been deceased oh [ __ ]
just like what the hell they were up so
t-mobile are they sweet texts at least I
get the person to see it's like I miss
you so they're creepy they're saying
that many people realize that the
messages were from Valentine's Day
earlier this
like really delayed text messages but
other people are saying like I don't
even send that message period boy okay
so this is all big liars
huh they just got like they got all
caught in their fields and then they're
like all over that person are you good
liars
yeah that text never went through it was
like I really miss you let's make it
work and then it didn't get sent to now
yeah that's like I already I told my
mind yeah yeah or if it was like last
night was amazing and like you're
married now or something like that like
you're so that was suck yeah there's
this company called
sinner verse and apparently they're the
ones behind these mass text message SMS
messages that have been recent or
delayed and so they're saying that there
were there was just this they're saying
that it's infrastructure maintenance oh
and caused old SMS messages to be
replayed and so subscribers may have
received all duplicate messages and that
their team is currently investigating to
determine the impact but a lot of people
start questioning questioning like what
the [ __ ] like why are these the why is
this other third party holding on to my
texts like why like yeah that's weird so
I don't know yeah why are they storing
on your [ __ ] I mean we're probably
storing everything everyone so they're
not responding to wive Shady how do they
have this personal text stone so they're
saying that easy that major providers
such as AT&T t-mobile Verizon Sprint
they use this this other company to
provide service so I don't know it's
kind of weird and so they were saying
that this maintenance ended up causing a
hundred and sixty eight thousand one
hundred and forty nine previously
undelivered text messages to be sent out
and so now they're apologizing like the
chief marketing and product officer said
in a statement we apologize to anyone
who was impacted by this occurrence but
there
looking to see what happened but a lot
of the people that have been affected or
not a lot but like like I previously
mentioned some of these people have
received messages from people that have
passed away like for example this one
Verizon employee said I had a customer
who was receiving the same text from her
son the son had passed away like six
months ago that's tough
nothing goes for sure maybe he really
wanted his message to get through maybe
some eat hold which in the whole system
yeah how cool would that be
it's like interstellar or imagine me
imagine like you were like breaking up
with someone ranks and say like I really
you know like I thought about it I don't
want to be like yeah and then all of a
sudden you're like God over it and then
your message gets sent six months later
she's like what that's fine yeah they're
saying it was a punch in the gut some
people that yeah that sucks but I mean
wouldn't that be like super sweet to
think about it in that way like oh he
passed away yeah he's thinking of me I
like this but better than the
trafficking one that [ __ ] was [ __ ]
scary but that shit's real so y'all
gonna be careful out there don't come
yet that's good to know yeah dude
it gets probably way worse how do you
know so many dangerous things bro I stay
watching true crime and I stay on
Twitter and I stay on crime drunky
podcast I just I'm paranoid all the
[ __ ] time but I like stay down you
know what their of what their Ebola no I
don't know you don't care about crying
that much then what about a knife you
have a knife I don't have anything I
want to reveal what I have I do we
should say yes you have it all a team
well today we're like Ryan editor was
telling us I'm gonna get all just
[ __ ] jacked with everything I'm gonna
prepare disclose right here
you know what scream the brass knuckles
are a felony in California more than I
know but a gun is a misdemeanor oh and
I'm [ __ ] getting a dime you get in
less trouble I need to go learn how to
like actually like just like use a gun
you know and just yeah Google that yeah
classy I like guns yeah that's a
protected it's nice to hold to feels
nice I don't know man every time I hold
a gun in my hand
oh my god it could kill someone within
the first couple down this Jerry first
couple times really scary
I hear gun education lowers gun crimes
rate no I mean this is plastic it's like
feeling the weight in like the metal is
powerful it's [ __ ] scary holding on
someone it feels like power like but do
you think if giving it like let's say
you learn how to do it and then you
carry a gun with you all the time and
then this guy pops up and he's like
looking [ __ ] crazy do you said oh no
I'll [ __ ] shoot [ __ ] so it's
Halloween and you guys you got a
trick-or-treater and [ __ ] this dude is
it escaped prison escaped victim a
kidnapping victim and he's like and
you're like no no no no it's like I
don't think I could ever own a gun
I really don't curl did you live in LA
you know you know I don't like telling
her all you should or not even like
that's what I'm saying protection or
whatever but I honestly will not own a
gun unless I know I'm willing to shoot
someone with big won't you [ __ ] and I'm
not so that's true cuz you don't want to
be like freeze off [ __ ] and endo be like
spit give me that [ __ ] [ __ ] if someone
comes in trying to get Isaac you
wouldn't shoot them [ __ ] yeah you would
yeah you would your mother and Steve
will [ __ ] do this probably my god
Isaac sure no I wouldn't rob at this
point but dude for real like I mean
depending on the situation but just I
don't think I could pull the trigger on
anyone you don't think until they have
to and it's like it's you or them you
always have to think like that it's your
them and it's gonna be them yeah I
really think I could gouge someone's
eyes out I think I could do that so much
harder to catch their eye versus the bad
guys Carlin how much in danger I need a
beat for me to hurt someone no no girl
you need to be like Rick's old flames
but you shouldn't even have to be there
you're too late that's in too deep down
yeah that's like I want them to be
choking me and I'm almost about to die
and then release the beasts I need to be
tied around a chair in another country
Manaka yeah I even have a knife to my
neck and everything and then I'm finally
gonna gouge his eyes up that's too late
dude you need it
you could keep some distance you want to
kiss me [ __ ] this but see like I
don't I would not be that calm though
like I would [ __ ] be trembling right
so that's why you just kind of shoot one
up boom I'm not [ __ ] around and
they'll be like oh shoot in the air a
warning shot scare the [ __ ] out of
people no no shoot at them shoot toward
them at the legs but what if they're
better at aiming and they have a gun I
know that's the thing I'm scared of
because I don't think I'm gonna a me
criminals never train so if you guys
train you're always gonna be yeah let's
take down glasses you're still shooting
like this let's own a [ __ ] gun
Stacey you ask the right questions
because people think it's so scared to
even think what you're thinking oh it's
just it's not bound to happen but that
sure happens all that's what I'm saying
the type that says if there's a zombie
apocalypse I'm killing myself that's
what I say you really want me to go out
there and get a gun but it's how you're
gonna kill yourself without a gun tip
true you slightly Oh God here's a
burglar I'm gonna [ __ ] bite his dick
off but it's like you had to do all that
you got this right here it's like why do
you wait till the last minute
Oh have you guys ever seen those videos
like on CCTV where like our robber comes
in it was like a restaurant I forgot
what it was in Citizen shoot back no and
this lady I love those ladylike grabs
the gun and she's like in the guys like
come up like he's gonna get it back and
then she goes boom and then like just
like you know because she's not never
shot a gun before he's like oh [ __ ] and
he just like takes off because he was
like [ __ ] and she's brave yeah but I
think when you're in those situations
like you're like it's either me or him
like I'm it's not gonna be me like you
just always have to think that way you
know yeah I don't know what I would do I
honestly think it's cuz I played sports
my whole life and I'm
tomatillos like it's here me or this
person like yeah no much tattooed they
have like women's only classes do for
for like the gun for the gun courses
yeah so a lot of times like not only I
think women are not not only are they
intimidated by this gun and it's all
heavy but I think also like they might
be intimidated by the environment where
they're like well how come I feel like
I'm so like unsure of myself and there's
all these guys are like overcompensating
or whatever I think there's there's
other classes that everyone could take
together and I'll feel good top my women
yeah I just think it's okay it's better
to know than to better to know it never
use than to be in the position for sure
but I'm the type that buys the [ __ ]
spiky thing to take with me instead of a
pepper spray
I want you want it to be this close that
doesn't make any sense
oh it's like you know I'm that close
then i'ma jump in my [ __ ] tank
and then I'm gonna [ __ ] crazy I hope
no no I ran that situation but why
that's how I take classes
let me avoid the most easiest thing
possible endings I want them but not die
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]